well there's a kid a lefty on the mound
fromber valdez and you see 11-8 came off
the injured list may 28 he will rely on
a big overhand curveball
his control has been a little issue a
lot of deep counts tim anderson stands
in one for four in game one yesterday
here's a bouncing ball toward the middle
correa to his left scoops it up throws
on the run and gets it
valdez appreciates it nice play going to
the glove side and having to throw kind
of against his body arm strength
accurate all of those things a great way
to start the game for the astros and the
bases are loaded for lloyd so a great
opportunity here
ground ball altuve smothers it flips to
second they get the out there as a run
scores fielder's choice rbi
for jimenez
roberts scores the first run it's one
nothing white sox they're at the corners
for jalon moncada
fans making noise hoping valdez can
close out the inning
which he does
they score one they strand two well you
hear the applause
for jose altuve but he'll face an
imposing presence on the mound six foot
six lucas giolito and white sox people
will say he has pitched much better than
that record four pitch pitcher has a big
overhand curveball and we'll look at how
he's changed his motion where he gets
the hand out of his glove almost like a
catcher so as you said buck they need a
good start from him
giolito gets him
prior to that he had not had much
success against altuve who coming into
this game was three for 10 against him
with two home runs now giolito has to
face another guy who's punished him
michael brentley
brantley
has faced giolito 12 times
six for 12 with a couple of home runs
how about that well he puts both altuve
and brantley away brantley doesn't
strike out much
the rare hitter
in modern baseball who walks more often
than he strikes out only 53 times this
year and bregman limited to 91 games
this year by a left quad strain another
2-2 pitch
he strikes out the side all three of
them swinging
good start
for the folks from the south side andrew
vaughn starts it in the top of the
second the o2
swing and a mess got him on the curve
ball inside and that is the second
strikeout for fromber one out uncle
charlie from valdez a good breaking ball
there to the right-hander so now the
switch hitting second baseman laurie
garcia 0 for three yesterday in game one
two quick strikeouts and three in a row
going back to the last out of the first
for valdez as garcia swings and misses
so two outs it's adam engel with the
base is clear one
they'll throw to first to make it
official
and as giolito did in his first inning
of work
valdez in his second frame strikes out
the side alvarez had an rbi double and a
long home run in game one
a little pop into foul ground with the
shift on racing over and unable to make
the play
is monkatta wow he got to it but
couldn't quite clutch it and he took a
hard slide into that pad i would hope he
doesn't have a knee injury or a foot
that was a a great effort
shaken up but staying in kyle tucker was
sizzling in september hitless with a
pair of strikeouts in game one and
tucker grounds it against the shift and
that's going to go in the left center
for a base hit around third and scoring
is yuli and the astros tie it at one
took advantage of that vacated hole on
the left side and just stroked it the
other way here's chas mccormick
and this one bounces away as the runners
move off correa the third and tucker to
second on the wild pitch
[Applause]
mccormick drives one to left it could
bring a run home jimenez makes the catch
the throw to the plate
not in time
and it's 2-1 astro so two on nobody out
for abreu who had a single in the first
struck him out fifth strikeout for
valdez big pitch on his signature pitch
there again you're gonna see the spin of
look at the rotation on that ball on one
now to grandahl who was hit by a pitch
in the first
tapper back to valdez on the mound goes
to second for the force over the first
double play
just like that
one to four to three
and valdez and the astros back in the
dugout here's montada
switch hitter batting right
slashed to first fielded smartly by
goriela steps on the bag now it's a tag
play and a double play
jimenez was stuck nothing he could have
done about it goriela's right on the bag
little fortune for the astros
slide of hand by guriel runner at first
time run here in the fifth adam engel at
the bat
that ball is ripped and into the glove
of bregman he throws
actually the ball got away from him
makes no difference
because garcia would have gotten back
anyway so they can laugh about it no
harm
go ahead and laugh about it
they win the day they'll be talking
about that on the plane to chicago today
robert with two on he's got a single
a walk and scored a run 1-0 pitch line
to left that ball is going to get in
there and up against the wall
leori will score
it's a long single for luis robert to
tie the game and they're at the corners
with only one out it's two to two there
it is
jose struck out in an rbi spot in the
30. singled back in the first he's got
three hits in the series the pitch
there's a liner base hit to center
here comes tim
and the white sox lead three to two
jose abreu whacked a little liner into
center field and they've got their
second advantage today still only one
out in the frame for yasmani grandal he
hit into an inning ending double play in
the third he's also been hit by a pitch
it bounces away
and runners will be at second and third
wild pitch a moment ago changed the
whole dynamic
and this one is lofted into left center
field not terribly deep
alvarez with a running start makes the
catch the throw to the plate is cut off
and the white sox pad their lead altuve
in third bregman at second the tying run
alvarez at first the go ahead run four
to two white sox upsteps goriel the
american league batting champion who's
over two today and oh for six in the
series and that's a crown ball up the
middle and through for a base hit altuve
scores bregman around third and coming
home he'll score as well julie ties it
with a two run single four to four
andrew vaughn has struck out twice
altuve with a lunging grab
soft line drive
that appeared headed for shallow center
field altuve up the middle with that
dive to take away a hit from vaughan
tucker had an rbi single then fouled out
the pitch to the left-handed hitting
tucker's line left center
caught
eloy left his feet
may had a little may have had a little
trouble with that ball in the lights but
he went down and he made the catch
brings up maldonado
he's flied out twice to right in the
pitch little tap on a check swing on the
ground back to the pitcher
throw to second one relay in time wow
they found a way to turn it i didn't
think they had a prayer that's a good
throw by topera to second base a long
throw from just in front of home plate
first robert is the runner at second now
you got ron dahl 0-2 pitch
in the air to right center field
for a moment as if tucker might have
misjudged it
but he reaches up
to haul it in and finish off the inning
so runners at the corners with one out
for jordan alvarez
grounder off the middle base hit
astros lead 5-4
jordon comes up big time
two out
two on a run home and the 3-1 pitch from
kimbrell to correa
line to right
garcia turns around and can't find it
two runs are going to score
on an opposite field double from correa
that was the product of the
power of correa i mean that ball was hit
like a line drive tucker who had an rbi
single in the second overall he's one
for three breaking pitch
riff to left field good one good night
two runs shot by kyle tucker
just like that it's nine to four
and it's lunacy at minutemaid park
jimenez will lead it off for chicago he
has an rbi on the fielder's choice one
for three
jimenez
rolls it toward the middle altuve with a
whirling throw off a backhanded gravity
got him that is some play
to get to it and then especially
to whirl and peg on target outstanding
play by jose altuve astros continue to
play great defense
yes monty grandall the last hope for
chicago 1-1
and that's it high in the air shallow
right side toward the line altuve over
in the foul territory tucker behind him
tucker reaches out and makes the catch
the houston astros take a commanding two
games to none lead in this best three
out of five alds
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes